يعني قبل ان اجيب على هذا السؤال دعيني
اؤكد لك بان مناطق شمال غرب سوريا الواقع
تحت سيطره المعارضه لم يدخل اليها اي شحنه
من المساعدات سواء من الامم المتحده
ومفوضيه سوريا اللاجئين او الهلال
لانه ممنوعين كلها كانت الامم المتحده
تتحدث عنه يعني وجود شحنات من المساعدات
عالقه على الطرف التركي واوعزت الاسباب
الى امور
لوجستيه هناك رغبه بمساعده المناطق
المنكوبه لكن الطقس انقطاع الطرقات كما
يعرف غسان في مناطق التركيه في الولايات
العشر المتضرره تعيق يعني او تؤخر على
الاقل دخول هذه المساعدات الى هذه المناطق
لكن ردا على سؤالك ميسون نعم يعني ليس
هناك حل سوى مطار دمشق الدولي سوى ميناء
موانئ اللاذقيه هذه الموانئ تقع تحت سيطره
النظام لا يوجد اتفاق سياسي بين المعارضه
النظام وبالتالي هذه الاشكاليه ستعرق
الجهود ادخال المساعدات الى المناطق
المنكوبه خاصه في ادلب والارياف الشماليه
والغربيه لحلب كما كما تفضلت مطار حلب
يبقى الحل الافضل في حال لو استطاعت الدول
المانحه والجهات المعنيه ايجاد صيغه تفاهم
مع الطرفين المعارضه ونظام لخلق جسر جوي
لاثقال المساعدات عبر وهو اعتقد الطريقه
الانجح